persecution often brings you to the
decision-making process and I look at
the Christian world today and I'm like
man what has happened to the Christian
World we've lost discernment you know
essentially Christianity has cooled
right have you ever had anything kind of
get scary
is wanting a group of people that are
all in in the end the extreme should be
extreme love extreme servanthood extreme
serving those others because that's what
Christ did does God want you to be
extreme find out on this episode of LED
live
foreign
welcome back everybody to an LED a
special extreme version you'll find out
why we're calling it that but we have an
awesome guest Justin Rittenhouse welcome
to the LED show again uh I'm excited to
have you here I'm excited to share some
stories if you haven't checked out uh
Justin's past LED that we did with him
and he tells some pretty crazy stories
this guy lives in Wisconsin and ends up
showing up here last couple of days so
we were like man we gotta we gotta do
something again show show us some more
cool stuff so you guys will be in for a
treat but welcome to the show Justin all
right thanks for having me so I'm
excited to go through some of the slides
and see how things are rolling nice
Justin has a really unique uh sort of
backstory I think that's special
um he has how many kids I have nine
children eight girls and one boy nine
children and this guy is an extreme
dream like passionate person about
everything he does in life
yeah you have to be with nine children
right yeah you gotta be like what's the
most common question you get about
having nine children uh how many diapers
have you went through throughout the
years
of changing diapers yeah years of
changes I'm professional I could
actually do a blinded folder I mean you
could probably toss them up and like
hold the diapers they go down you're
good to go yeah on to the next one but I
think there's something really neat and
and precious about your family and uh I
saw this article Justin uh was in the
newspaper in his local Hometown I think
that's where this came from correct look
at what they wrote about him this is
really interesting Justin written house
has jumped out of an airplane a hundred
times climbed Mount St Helens built a
bike to ride in a race that he was
racing in the very next morning and
competed in an Iron Man hiked to the
Grand Canyon this week and has nine
children including eight girls and he
will be a grandpa coming this December
yes that's extremely amazing it's a
little intense so but that's the way you
got to live life so all in so I'm I'm
excited to kind of hear a little bit
about what is it like to have nine
children children here's a picture of
not all of them eight of them right
eight of them yep my oldest is not here
with her husband uh on this trip in
particular this is in February and now
what is this vehicle that you have
behind you so this is our shuttle boss I
mean when you have that sheltered how do
you how do you roll you got to roll some
way especially if you travel or do all
kinds of stuff so This Is How We Roll
how do you do anything I mean it's like
probably the woman in the Shoe Right
porridge
you know it really helps the kids are
just totally awesome I mean the hands
down um they have the privilege of being
able to homeschool which is part of it
too and it's so good because everybody
works together but you have to work
together as a team you do yeah we
actually had one time where somebody
came on over and I was watching because
we always end up with more kids so at
our house there's like our kids plus
there's more kids that come and I was
watching for some moms that went out so
I had maybe I don't know 16 18 kids and
um one of the kids needed to have their
diaper changed and the brother was like
10 years old and I said oh you know all
your your sister needs her diaper change
can you do that he just froze like
nobody's ever asked him that before
Faithfully I talk to my girls I'm like
uh girls can you help out because you
know it's just not normal but for our
house that's normal everybody has to put
it I mean it's probably like NASCAR
right you just don't jack the baby boys
10 seconds later you've got a baby yeah
a lot of people say well how do you do
for like food well my six-year-old she
can make you know oatmeal so it's basic
she can make eggs so you know up to my
six-year-old can cook for everybody too
which is pretty amazing now I know what
it's in my house Keith has four kids so
he he's got a half of a taste of this
yeah what happens if they all want
something different too bad so sad
you're rolling with much tonight yeah
you holding me like I'm sorry yes I
understand too bad that's so awesome so
let's let's uh introduce them to you uh
here's a here's uh them saying all high
right here check this out hello I'm
Justin Rittenhouse and I'm the father of
The Rittenhouse crew right next to me we
have the poora and I'm 15 years old I'm
Mahalia and I'm 14 years old I'm nav and
I'm 11 years old my name is Zion and I'm
the only boy and I'm 10 years old I'm
just asking and I'm eight years old and
I'm six years old I'm seeing it and I
have five
all right and this is what we have this
is what we drive around in because of
course when you have nine children you
need a vehicle to get around in so come
on let's check it out
ah yeah whatever
all right you guys sit down there sit
down sit down sit down
so this is what we have in here so we
got a couple tables and we got uh two
queen beds a twin bed we put up some
blinds we do have some LED lights and uh
this right here is he bugs out if you
want to have the door open in the summer
two captains chairs it's important does
drive by the way
Is How We Roll on our adventures
anything else you guys
on the next ones
and that's pretty much How We Roll so
kids are hanging off walls so on and so
forth I bet you there is no quiet time
at your house no no early early in the
morning that's it so what time do you
have to wake up to beat the youngest
waking up or the oldest I don't know
which one wakes up early yeah I think
it's right around 4 30 is a good time if
you want to have that quiet time so so
everything you do is enlarged You by and
large you drive in large yeah and I
buy in bulk yeah seriously okay okay I
got a story
um so long story short we like this
organic cereal that we get and they have
like 25 ounce bags or whatever well
usually twice a year they have a sale at
this one grocery store we go to so what
we've done well what I've done I guess
you could say this is what I buy I buy
for like the whole time so I had the
eight by eight foot bed of my truck I
had the whole thing loaded with cereal
it was 130 130 bags of cereal is what I
got for that because hey you get half
price off you got to load up you're
going to eat it question is though how
long did it last you know to be honest
it doesn't last as long as normal people
would think it's the same thing about 50
50 pound bag of oatmeal okay how long
would they normally last somebody and
I'm saying only maybe maybe three days a
week two three days a week that you'd
have oatmeal how long would that last a
normal family months that would last me
a long time a month and a half
50 pound bags of oatmeal that's crazy
yeah that's reality that's what you're
looking at crazy I I love it though and
I know the Bible has a lot to say about
like many children right it's a blessing
yes in fact the the words that are used
I think is if your quiver is full right
I don't remember these exact words but
uh what a blessing this is and it is I
absolutely I feel so privileged so
honored to have those kids I'm gonna
joke around I'm like yeah we have nine
kids so far you never know you never
know you never never know what the
future holds but I absolutely love kids
they're they're fun they're blessing I
mean adults they have all those like
stops in place and maybe that's why I
relate to them so much because they're
like yeah let's do it I'm like okay
I love it and and you know is there is
there like some lesson life lesson that
you've learned along the way that maybe
you you didn't think you were gonna
learn that and now all of a sudden you
have a lot of it so you know I have a
strong personality and I'm active type
person and a lot of times even with kids
even though they're active it's almost
like Moses going through the Red Sea you
can only go so fast and I just learned
like sometimes it's gonna take however
long it takes people are like okay where
are you gonna be I'm like yeah we'll try
to be here at this time but that's what
we worked towards so I never have like
hard times because the reality is
anything can happen at any given moment
so yeah it's it's pretty amazing that is
really amazing and if I look over your
Facebook account
um it looks like you are actively
engaged with every single one of them
all the time yeah that is really a neat
skill that you have one of the things
that we do now is I try to rotate just
because so many kids so I take I took my
15 and my 14 while 16 and 14 year olds
you'll be 15 next month out on dates so
I took them on a date so then I took the
eight-year-old and the 12 year old out
on a date then my son I do something
with and then we call them the three
littles four five and six actually soji
will be seven tomorrow so but we call
them the three little so everybody that
we talked to referred to him as the
littles so then you take those out and
try to rotate that because I want them
to know for one I want them to know that
they're love for two I want them to know
how how a guy should treat them yeah
yeah and I mean I can imagine like the
amount of energy that takes to be able
to spend the needed time especially them
all being girls I mean you are huge in
their world you know and and even your
son I mean just growing up with the
father figure it is really neat to see
how much engagement you actually give
them do you even work
yeah God's really God's really done
amazing things um because like we
started from nothing literally and God's
really blessed the work of my hands and
really have allowed us to be able to do
all the things we do because we're a
crazy active family and most families
that are this big are not as active you
know together they just don't do all the
things but we go on trips we go on lots
of trips all the time because I look at
this this is the prime time you know all
the other stuff like I'll work till I'm
80 or do whatever like none of that
matters the most important time is right
now as they're developing I want them to
know Christ and I want them to know you
know I've been through a lot of stuff
you know like you reference back of when
when we did an interview
um you know a while back I've been
through you name it been there done that
and I'm just trying to build into the
kids what a healthy mindset a healthy
frame is so I I love the fact that
whatever you're approaching it's like
you you don't just sort of like okay
maybe we'll try this it's like no we're
going to do this and it's going to be
awesome
and it's just like everything is so epic
and and it
just if I didn't know and I met you on
the street and you all of a sudden
dropped on me that you had nine children
I would go of course you did
why wouldn't you you know yeah I've hung
out with you guys and the awesome kids
man uh they're so like I see that
they're growing in the Lord you're doing
something right I've seen you
um do Bible studies with your kids and
you're teaching them hand motions to
remember scripture and it's a beautiful
thing man yeah we have um so we do Bible
studies at my parents on Thursday night
um and we do we do an array of different
things they're traditional for a family
just to help build connections but uh on
those Thursday nights my my third oldest
daughter she'll actually take a lot of
the little kids and she'll actually she
actually made a whole program for it so
my second oldest and my third oldest my
third oldest does the program my second
oldest does hand motions and does with
different songs so they'll actually
learn hand motions by her like they do
all their own and then they come down
when we have worship and singing just
before they go to their different
classes and um yeah it's just beautiful
like every day I'm just like what a
privilege it is to be a father to watch
these kids and just to be involved with
them like I'm just so super super
thankful for that I mean if you had any
more kids you'd have to start doing
first service and second service
just like so much activity you can
imagine your house is probably
constantly buzzing yeah it's it's
definitely and like I say it's not just
our kids and our house you know neighbor
kids come over we always have so many
people because it's really cool because
they really feel it as a safe place so a
lot of kids that may be going through
different stuff they'll come by too and
just want to be able to have that safe
place too so it's a blessing it's
awesome
um I wanted to uh show you a little
video of what it's like to actually roll
around on a daily basis I don't even
know where you're going on this one
where were you going I was we're
actually going to Chicago uh Museum of
Science and industries and this was
actually just a couple weeks ago
um and then of course some of the
parents there's a Homeschool Group that
was going and all the kids of course
want to go in the shuttle bus so the
parents are like yeah no problem you can
take the kids we'll have a quiet ride
I'm like okay
yeah if each of them brought a friend I
mean that's a whole school yeah I think
we had 16 kids in here
um so I had eight of mine and then eight
extra so that is really amazing okay
check this out
how's everybody doing
where are we going
are we going to Chicago
are we going to be here besides an
industry
yeah you guys excited
bye
maybe it's like a school outing
everywhere you go I love that there's
beds though yeah and before anybody gets
on starts writing comments like where's
the seat belts why aren't the kids in
there you don't need seat belts when
you're in a 26 000 pound vehicle yeah so
you do it all the time at the airport so
so anyway just for technicalities you
don't need them legally in there the
school bus has never had seatbelts
correct correct that is really amazing
so not only Justin is uh you know
extreme with his family activities but
you even find time to do things that
very rarely do do it does anybody get a
chance to do yeah what are you doing
right here uh this is uh I joined a
group called F5 and uh this is where we
climb Mount St Helen uh Helens sorry so
we claimed Mount St Helens and it was it
was pretty intense as you can kind of
see this was before it got even worse as
we were climbing and uh yeah you can
check it out so what what is F5 just to
explain a little bit so F5 is Faith
Fellowship Fitness fun and fortitude
it's a group has about 5 000 members and
they do stuff all over the world a lot
of the stuff they do is
um is in the United States and they
based originally in the west you know
the west side so California that whole
area Washington and so they do they do
active stuff this particular trip we
actually helped the family who had 14
kids rhymed with disabilities so there
were five kids with disabilities they
had 14 kids so we actually went there we
helped them with their house helped them
do all kinds of stuff that they weren't
able to do and then after that we ended
up climbing Mount St Helens so it's a
group that does all kinds of positive
things and those active things too so
it's a really really cool group super
cool that is really cool I know Calvin
Kim is one of the guys that started
working on that way back when and uh
he's a dentist and I love it that he
he's gotten this whole group excited
about these kind of things and I've run
into people in South Africa I was
walking on this trail and I think I was
wearing an F5 red shirt and somebody
comes up and goes like oh wow are you
doing the F5 stuff too and I was like
this yeah it's a really cool like uh you
know Calvin he's done Iron Man as well
um yeah so I mean they're they're tough
tough dudes that have done all kinds of
stuff not just dudes but it's everybody
yeah so they're they're really really
good programs and they challenge each
other too so you you kind of like uh
will inspire someone to either lose
weight or you know try to like really
work something so we actually did the
annual retreat in Sedona Arizona and I
think we might have a couple pictures
from that but when we went there they
actually have different levels so of
course I did level five the most extreme
obviously but uh so they have different
levels depending on where you're at you
know so a lot of people saying like oh
well doing all this stuff that's a lot
but they actually have stuff for
different levels of people so it
includes everybody so it's it's a really
really good program and the people are
just they're top-notch people so so if
anyone out there is saying I don't have
time for this or that or whatever and
you don't have nine kids here is an
example of someone that does not take
the excuse and actually gets out there
and does some pretty extreme things now
is this you with the snowboard strapped
to your back no no no that was actually
Calvin to be honest with you yeah yeah
so my dad in high school
um used to take us snow camping all the
time and my brother and I got the bright
idea one time to backpack our snowboards
up there which you needed snowboard
boots and other things to go with you we
climbed up to the top of this mountain I
was so exhausted by the time I even got
on the thing the snow was so deep and so
heavy that we couldn't even go down the
hill it was just like I'm done it sounds
funny but that actually particularly
Mount Saint Helens climb they had 15
inches of snow two days before 12 inches
or so the next day so 27 inches of snow
and they actually said ah maybe we
should call this off but some of us I
was one of them were like no we got this
I mean you know we got this so we
actually started going up that was an
experience I'm guessing the person that
was recording stayed behind yeah yeah
yeah there's a lot of people that kind
of uh
so what is this Justin so yeah so I I
love skydiving so it was a bucket list
thing and I'm like okay you know a few
years ago I'm like okay I just wanted to
go skydiving and as soon as I went I
landed I signed up for my license I went
two more times that day so the first
time I went yeah the first time I went
skydiving went three times and how many
times have you jumped out I jumped 100
times so yeah yeah and I love it I love
flying in the air this is actually part
of free fly but anyways have you
strapped anything like done this done
the board or anything like that knocked
on the board yet and there's different
levels and different license uh that you
a b c and d
um so yeah so this is just just me
jumping right now I'm sure by the time I
plan on jumping to him 100 I mean really
amazing now have you ever had anything
kind of get scary
statistically wise they call it cut away
or break away
um if there's a major malfunction with
your original parachute you have a
secondary parachute Reserve yeah a
reserve and typically
um you know I I talked to a guy he had
three thousand jumps never had to use
his reserve you know but typically it's
maybe once every 700 jumps it's like 3
000 3 000 jobs yeah there's there's guys
that have 20 000 plus but
um every 700 jumps or so you might have
to pull a reserve is the statistical
thing well I just got my license a
couple jumps prior to this event it was
my 30th jump and uh I go I pull and
actually snap my brake line which is
your steering and everything else so
somehow it snapped and I'm in the air I
look at my altitude and I know how much
time I have with my altitude I'm playing
in the air because I know statistically
you can land it with your front and rear
risers but I have no clue I just got my
license I'm playing within the air I'm
like if I try to land this way I'm going
to break something or hurt myself so I
finally just like okay so I cut it away
on my 30th jump and I ended up Landing
down in my reserve and everybody's like
you had to cut away what happened yeah
I'm sorry I mean I don't know you know
just the idea of holding a knife to your
your safety device well you just
actually pull so you go like this you
pull it and it cuts it away the
interesting thing that particular day
most people will see that you cut away
yeah and nobody saw that I cut away on
top of that when I land my parachute
flew off into the swamp they actually
had to fly the plane because the you
know it's like a couple thousand dollars
for that you know so they actually flew
the plane up had the circle around to
find out where it is take a picture come
back down we had to go through a swamp I
ended up with poison ivy all over my
body yeah of course
and then you probably packed it right up
like when you went back home that night
were you just like okay I'm gonna not do
this for a little while or are you just
just like well I was like I'm not gonna
share this story right away we're gonna
hold off on that one but I was I don't
know I was fine with it I knew like you
know the procedure like okay if you have
an issue okay you cut away and you land
the other one yeah I jumped out of an
airplane when I turned 18 years old and
and it was one of the one of the few
highlights I remember just being like
yeah that was amazing that was
absolutely amazing like I I could see
getting into that as a thing everybody
should do it yeah hands down so the rule
at my house is as soon as you turn 18 we
go jumping so that's the rule so my
older starter did it my parents have
jumped like yeah my parents had told my
daughter when she turned 18 my oldest
daughter she had friends jump I jumped
my parents jumped all the way around you
get your parents into it well they just
jumped that one time that was all they
did were they already into it or did you
oh that was me yeah and that was I was
like dude you gotta I think everybody
should jump at least once because the
experience is like you're not able to
explain it people are like well how is
them like you just gotta jump yeah I
think the most fearful thing wasn't
actually when you're out of the plane I
think it's when we were corkscrewing to
get up high enough I was the one that
was sitting right next to the window and
it's like you know this this like you
stand at the edge of a cliff long enough
you seem to get more and more scared and
I was just like Are We Really Gonna
Leave This perfectly good airplane like
I don't know if I want to do that but
once you get to the door they actually
don't let you turn around like the the
next year well the group the group that
I did said like if we get to the door
you're going so there's no question
about it you know so I tell everybody if
you get nervous you know and you're up
in the plane and you all you got to do
is say no no because it's so loud no
sounds like go so if somebody says no no
you're like okay
that's so amazing all right so on his F5
challenges uh you've done some pretty
cool climbs all over uh what is this one
this is when we're in the uh Grand
Canyon Bright Angel uh Bright Angel
Trail and uh this was so beautiful it
was just the whole scene was just
amazing and this is one of the times
where we hiked down there and uh we took
this picture part of the Grand Canyon
area so wow that's pretty intense
obviously you do not have a fear of
heights yeah how far down is that uh man
I don't know it's far enough yeah yeah
what I like about this picture is if you
notice the person in the background
isn't even looking So Justin's not like
hey everybody look at me it says like
hey I want to jump over that
yeah that was I got yelled at for that
one that's awesome
so you know there is some really
interesting spiritual things I think
that that really
um pertain to going all in and that just
seems like to be what you are like you
know I see your passion you you you love
to to to just dive in and it's not like
you sort of have to it you know we're
gonna go skydiving wait no I want to go
again and again and again you know and
so uh listen to what he says in
Revelation 12 11 and they overcame him
by the blood of the lamb and by the word
of their testimonies and they did not
love their lives even unto death I think
the spiritual lesson here is really like
God is wanting a group of people that
are all in in the end yeah that their
whole mentality is like nope I'm so sold
out to God that I don't I have no
interest in in defying or defiling God
or anything that he says I want to
follow him and I want to do it with my
whole heart and I think that is
beautiful and you know it reminds me of
and I was talking to my kids and praise
God my kids did not have to go through
some of the experiences that I went
through but when you get the pain of of
bad choices the pain of sin the pain of
Destruction you don't ever want to be
anywhere close to that you know so um I
try to tell the kids you know every
person has to make their decision in
life whatever that is but I try to share
with them the experiences that I've been
through to say hey this is the reality
of of what happens to avoid that and uh
praise God so far they they seem to they
know that I love them they listen to
that and say no you know I can hear you
and that's enough I don't have to go
there you know yeah so yeah that's what
that's important to do when I look at
your family your children and stuff none
of them seem like they're really
rebellious or a regional phase like that
I wonder if they kind of witness to each
other you got such a big family it's
like a youth group you know no and
that's honestly that's that's what
happens you know they do encourage each
other and that's why it's such a
privilege to be involved in that at
because
um yeah they're continuing they're doing
Bible studies on their own they're doing
different things on their own and they
can be a blessing to me you know and
everybody else and that really speaks to
the parenting skills because you know
kids are going to do what the parent
does right if you treat religion uh
laxidasically or you know it's like I
don't really feel like waking up and
studying this morning your kids
recognize that kind of stuff and so you
know it's neat to see you actively
engaged in having family worships and
you know studying the Bible with them
and and you can see it in your kids like
what Mikey said I don't see any of them
as like you know really you know I'm
sure every kid yeah
but no he's he has such a soft heart but
he has an intensity so uh yeah he can be
uh active and peace to the puzzle that's
a whole nother that's a whole other
story yeah
so continuing on this kind of idea of of
God wanting us to be all in
um listen to what it says in Revelation
3 3 15 and 16. Mike you want to read
that yeah it says I Know Thy works that
thou art neither hot nor cold I would
that thou are cold or hot so then
because Thou Art lukewarm and neither
cold nor hot I will spew or some
translation say vomit thee out of my
mouth
so you know he wants us all in if we're
not if we're one foot in the world one
foot in the church he says he's going to
spew you out of his mouth you know and I
look at the Christian world today and
I'm like man what has happened to the
Christian World we've lost discernment
we've lost our uh are all in this
whatever that whatever word that is but
we're just we we want that I just see
people saying I want this ticket Free
Ticket Out of Hell type thing but I'm
going to live my life how I want to and
it's even gotten so bad that I see like
when I show people like look this is
what the Bible says this this and this
they'll be like you know what I don't
need that I live by by the Holy Spirit
guides me or something what a deception
you know like we live in a time where
people are just following their heart
following their their Intuition or
whatever but the Bible is clear you know
when it says certain things and well how
do you make warm water
uh one more you heat it up you heat it
up but you know if you're heating it up
it started with like cold right you're
mixing hot with cold and stuff yeah and
I see this is like like you said there
is such a mixture in today's society we
do not like actually say you know what I
want I want to serve God with all of my
heart if God said it I'll do it you know
if if he's got it in his word there's a
reason why it's in his word and I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna listen to that
that's a good way to put it like if
something's cold it's cold if
something's hot it's hot but if it's
lukewarm there must be a mixture of
light and darkness and the Bible says
you can't mix light and darkness and it
says uh there's some other
things you know I was just saying that
we should we can't serve two masters and
things like this you know yeah either
you'll hate one and love the other it's
one or the other and a lot of times in
this world you know it's like okay like
I want to serve God but I want to hold
on to whatever it is there's these you
know pet sins or whatever it is and all
it does it's rottenness to our body it's
the cancer that affects us and none of
us are immune to it we got a daily say
Lord take this from me because I'm not
able to deal with it but you can do all
things through me and I know that and I
believe that and I stand on your word
amen amen it's like we're clinching on
to some poison like no I just want this
and it's like no it's killing you I mean
people that smoke you know people you
care about you're like please give this
up they're like no or something they
want to let it go but they can't it was
like I know so many people that smoke
that say I hate it I wish I didn't do it
you know but they're just get wrapped up
into it yeah I can give you the freedom
to break those chains so what's
interesting to me is the historical
context of this verse laodicea where it
was positioned when it got its water it
got it through an aqueduct system the
you know in that part of the the world
they were good at developing uh
aqueducts to get their water and the
water came from a hot spring
and so by the time that it got to them
it was only lukewarm it wasn't just you
know hot anymore because of the travel
or something yeah because there's some
distance and of course you know
um yeah over time and distance it's just
going to cool down it's not going to be
the same temperature you know it's just
like if you were boiling a pot of water
and then took it off the burner it's
going to cool down yeah same same kind
of idea and so that's exactly what you
were talking about is you know
essentially Christianity has cooled
right yeah over over time and that's
that's from the very beginning because
if you look at the way the churches are
described in
um Revelation chapter two when Jesus
first starts out and he's telling them
their conditions
um
they're more on fire right they're now
they have a few problems some of them
have left left their first love but
um
that was a place in time that if you
were a Christian it could cost you your
life yeah we're not we're not there
right now right and so the way history
goes and the way these churches go is
describing the church Through Time hello
Odyssey is the last one that's us yeah
last one yeah and so it's just this is
what the Jesus is saying this is the way
the church is now you know it's
unfortunate but um persecution often
brings you to the decision-making
process you really will see what
people's Christianity is truly made of
when you're faced with extreme you know
situations yeah even Peter denied Christ
right after he said I'll die with you I
mean he cut off the ear of the high
priests with his son servants or
something like that yeah yeah because he
was ready to go it was go time and then
like you know literally half the night
later he's like denying even knew him
yeah it's extreme on both sides though I
mean God's people have to be extreme
because of the the response
you know if somebody's like
we're just going to kill you yeah you
know yeah those extremes yeah we're just
gonna off you because you believe this
way that's true yeah it is messed up
yeah yeah that's really extreme to think
that way I can't imagine doing anything
even remotely like that to somebody
because they believe differently than me
right right that's right yeah it is a
crazy thought but I think this is the
picture that that you know God is really
promising to for his end time people
he's saying look I'm going to produce a
people that love not their lives even on
to death you know what I mean and and
what an extreme view that is and I know
some people can take it I think there
needs to be a separation between someone
who's just absolutely insanely extreme
because if they don't have the element
of Love mixed with the obedience
um yeah then it's all you know you see a
lot of people that will just get angry
and yell at people and you know that you
don't feel any kind of love and and
that's what I think you know Corinthians
talks about hey if you're if you have
all these things correct and you do it
not in love then you're a clinging
symbol the extreme should be extreme
love extreme servanthood extreme serving
those others because that's what Christ
did he was the extreme servant for us
laying down his life for us that's the
type of extreme that that Christ asked
us and he says I can do that through you
that's right you know that's right it's
him that's doing it yes
um in Matthew 22 37-40 Keith go ahead
and read this can you read it yeah Jesus
said to him you shall love the Lord your
God with all your heart with all your
soul and with all your mind this is the
first and great commandment and the
second is like it you shall love your
neighbor as yourself on these two
Commandments hang all the law and the
prophets I don't think we speak of these
Concepts enough there's a disconnect a
lot in the Christian world with well the
Ten Commandments don't matter anymore
right and it's like you know who cares
those were nailed to the cross and we
don't need to follow those but look at
what this is saying this is literally
saying like if you loved God with all
your heart that's an extreme love for
God you're not going to have another God
I'm not going to use his name in vain
you're not going to you know defy defy
his his Commandments and things so
um you know but I like how it puts out
there that you need to love with all
your heart your mind and your soul in
Matthew 5 6 and 7 serving on the mount
that much more you know what I'm saying
if you look at a woman in lust after you
you know all these different things it's
not just the literal you know Ten
Commandments it's deeper God calls us
you know uh whatever Matthew 5 verse 48
be perfect even as your father in Heaven
is perfect right God's calling us to a
Perfection that we're not able to do but
once again he can do that through us
that's right we just need to get
connected to the vine and let his
life-giving power flow through us right
so the danger of of getting to
um the end of the world and compromising
now is the testing time now is the time
that we're training ourselves to not
compromise in these little areas right
and I think that's why I like you know
it's it's neat to have somebody on board
that like that like understands the All
or nothing you know kind of mentality uh
I often am that person in my in my fam
family it's like if we're gonna do it
let's do it let's do it like it
wholeheartedly and I think that there is
a reason why uh I think God is is is
wanting us to understand this concept
now because the time's coming when
compromise is going to be the the thing
and in Colossians I don't remember
exactly I think it might be chapter
three but I'm not 100 but it says unless
you are faithful in small matters you
won't be faithful in larger ones good
point it's the small things that were
obedient to God with it's not like oh
yeah well when this happens I'll Stand
Strong no if you're not in those little
things you're not going to be in those
big things that's right that's where I
was going with the story of Daniel it
starts early and it starts young you
know so Daniel gets to battle on first
test is like what are you gonna eat
something that seems so innocent and
people fight against that all the time
yeah you know and I don't want to go off
on a tangent but are we eating to
glorify God the time that we have
throughout the day are we using that at
to glorify God or am I using that to
glorify me am I using either glorify
Justin am I using that because that's
what I want and it's that selflessness
that's in God it's between us and God
what what happens it's between us and
God he wants us to walk out that he'd be
obedience piece by piece by piece
because if we're being faithful in those
little matters those big matters won't
even be a question I don't I don't know
if this is just true in my life for me
and my wife but it seems like the more
knowledge that you have the more god
holds you responsible yes it's like you
can't get away with it yes yeah so when
I was in my 20s I'd kick back like a lot
of Mountain Dew a lot of soda you know
ate a lot of junk and it doesn't seem
like it was all that sensitive to it
like I could just do it and maybe it was
because I was younger but now it's like
I have to be and I because it's like I
know I have to really watch my sugar
intake I have to watch my water intake I
have to watch all these things and I
know it's the best way for me and when I
follow it I feel good when I don't
follow it it seems like the least little
thing you start to deviate and it's like
you go down never used to be that way
you know never used to be that way and I
think God gives us these little tiny
tests all throughout every day that you
have to make that that wise choice that
wise choice and I say wise choices is
some things God is like nope don't do
this right and other things he's giving
us the principles and letting us pick it
and we need to choose the higher road so
to say right but the more that you do
that the more that you say I'm doing it
because I want to do it for God and and
God is is asking me to do it and so
therefore I I want to to do that there's
a blessing that comes along with it I I
talk a little bit about like uh health
food when I kind of began to date my
wife I loved white pancakes like just
the whiter flower I mean this is
something about flour eggs milk sugar
and water there's something about it
right and my wife was like uh-uh we're
gonna eat some buckwheat you know and I
was like this stuff looks like cardboard
and it tastes like cardboard and and the
more that she fed that to me the better
I actually felt to the point where I
mean I've eaten you know white floured
pancakes in in my adult life since then
but I feel better eating the weeder ones
and I and I like that idea so I think
that there's a blessing that comes along
with with really living up for
principles of am I eating to live a
healthy life or am I eating because my
small member of my body my taste buds
want it yeah there's a some family
friends of ours they did something
really neat when they got married they
said
what when we have to come to make a big
decision in our life we're going to take
the
the one that's the most high road if we
disagree you know that's a good plan
that's a really good idea so it didn't
matter who it was it was just like
whatever the higher Road was out of the
two that's the one they were going to go
with yeah it's making me think of the
concept in Luke 12 48 where it says but
he that knew not and did commit things
worthy of Stripes shall be beaten with
few stripes for unto whomsoever much is
given of him shall be much required and
to whom men have committed much of him
they will ask the more so it's very King
Jamesy way of just saying you know the
more you know the more that's required
of you if you know this is wrong or this
is right then you're expected more than
somebody who is ignorant of that thing
ax talks about that God Winks at your
sins committed in ignorance so you know
you got some guy on the street who maybe
you've been to church once in a while
when he was a kid and he's doing this
sinful acts he doesn't know of it he's
gonna there's gonna be a lot less
punishment for him or it might even be
completely overlooked on Judgment Day
whereas the preacher on stage who's
doing who's a hypocrite and doing
everything that he knows is wrong is is
held up to a higher standard yeah and in
our world man we just see so much just
partial commitment well I'm going to
follow God if it's just convenient to my
schedule and when it's not convenient to
my schedule I'm going to do what I want
to do first and then okay if I don't got
anything else going on the weekend I'm
going to go to church like we don't
treat God as no you're number one I'm
gonna order you number one the rest of
it comes second and third and fourth and
everything else you know and we miss it
go ahead we don't treat him like a king
like the king of the universe our lord
of our life it's like he seems to be
like second yeah even in a lot of things
like I try it my way try my way try it
my way it fails okay Lord You're My Last
Resort and then he comes through and
it's like he should have in the first
one we went to the Bible says in in
First Peter 2 22 that says he says he
committed no sin nor was deceit found in
his mouth and at First John 3 5 it says
and you sh you know that he was
manifested to take away our sins and in
him there is no sin so
I think the reason for the you know all
in or all out is God's like look there's
no sin in me sin is what kills you yeah
so you either all in with me and and I
want that because I want you to live
because if there's a part of you that
wants this it's going to kill you that's
just the bottom line
so little by little this is the testing
ground this is the practice ground
um you know anybody you don't just go
fly out and and get a gun in your hand
and go out to War I mean those people
train for a long time and different
scenarios so that when that arises what
are you gonna do how are you going to
handle this and I think God's doing the
same thing he's he's preparing us the
end of the world is a time that will not
be like any other time on the face of
this planet and when I look at like
things that have happened in this planet
like the Holocaust is pretty pretty
crazy yeah there's some pretty crazy
things that have happened on this planet
and we're going to go through something
worse in the end now's the time that we
better get these Concepts now we gotta
hold on to God and and and wrap our
hearts our minds and our souls around
him and doing what he's asking us to do
he wants us to be extreme
totally
so uh go ahead and read this
um Mikey but seek first the kingdom of
God and his righteousness and all these
things shall be added unto you I think
that's like you know if you're talking
about extreme seeking the kingdom of God
you can't even see it you know seeking
that first instead of the things of this
world the Bible also says store not
Treasures for yourself on Earth but
store them up in heaven you know and
that seems like an extreme view but
that's what he wants from us because
it's good for us I love God's economy
you know okay tithing you know giving
money you know how does giving money you
know what I'm saying how does that bless
you and benefit you it just doesn't make
sense to the world like the world's like
how does that work yeah but in God's
economy it does yeah exponentially it
does yeah you know way more above and
beyond we think of literal money and it
can be a benefit that way too but it's
so much more and it's trust and faith
that God is calling us out when we seek
his Kingdom First Watch what's going to
happen trust me and watch what I do I'll
give you life and give it more
abundantly I don't know if it's like the
next verse or if it's just somewhere
else in the Bible but it talks about
when he's saying uh you know the birds
they don't worry about what they eat and
the flowers are dressed beautifully and
stuff it's like I mean God provides
every day yeah you know uh there's
another verse here that that I want to
kind of bring out about King David I
love the story of King David do you know
he's one of the most spoken about
characters in The Bible and
um Jesus constantly was referencing him
in fact when Jesus died on the cross he
said my God why have Thou forsaken me
right that was a direct quote from
David's word Psalms 22 and in the end of
the book of Revelation
um there is a verse in there that even
Jesus was or God was saying you know
that he was the son of David I mean that
that was an important figure in the
Bible right and listen to this verse it
says and when he had removed him meaning
Soul he had raised up unto them David to
be their King to whom he gave their
testimony and said
I have found David the son of Jesse a
man after my own heart and here's the
really important part of the verse which
shall fulfill all my will wow because
Soul was chosen by God God picked Saul
to be the first king and Saul did not
live a obedient life to God in fact in
the end of his life it was a terrible
obedience and and he began to just
completely lose his connection with God
and so as as God was basically saying
look I want David to be my my my king
now because he will do all my will David
was extremely passionate about doing
God's will I mean go read the Psalms he
constantly was saying um I I Delight to
do your will oh God your Commandments
and your judgments they're like you know
water to me you know like he he just had
this you know real passion about
following what God had done of course he
slipped up and there's examples of that
and uh but I I believe that to have the
heart that God would call one like his
own
is an obedient heart yeah all in go
ahead and read this one then he said to
them all if anyone desires to come after
me let him deny himself take up his
cross daily and follow me for whatever
desires to save his life will lose it
but whoever loses his life for my sake
will save it talk about extreme man
that's completely flipped from what we
think you know it's like I gotta I gotta
earn it and get it in this you know I
gotta be on top and it's like no whoever
will lose their life will gain it in its
servanthood it's extreme serpent Hood to
the point of losing our life that's
right you know that's right on yourself
but I also want to point out it's it's a
daily thing yes it's not just I said
this prayer when I was nine I'm good I'm
good to go I can live my life but it's
picking up your cross daily and
following him you have to to follow you
have to keep going yeah and and then we
need Christ every day we need his holy
spirit we need his strength to do that
but you're not going to get that unless
you commune with him get in his word all
those things and then he'll help us to
surrender to the things of this world
that we've been you know accustomed to
you know that's right it's interesting I
don't know that that line of reasoning
Works in a whole lot of other areas of
our life right you know you can't go to
your life and I was like I was faithful
on the first night you know yeah so what
I mean doesn't that apply the rest of
the time I mean are you getting pulled
over by the cop I mean I was I mean I
wasn't speeding yesterday yeah
so I don't I don't I don't think it
works but we apply that to our
Christianity and that's yeah we we kind
of walk on God like he's a doormat it's
not yeah we there's a lot of parts of
life that have you know obedience built
into that I think you know driving is a
really good example of that actually uh
you know if if everybody was just like I
don't really need to follow this the
speed limits and I don't need to follow
the the traffic signs I'm just going to
do whatever I want to do because I need
to get from A to B this is a concept
that I have to understand you've been
you've traveled a lot there's a lot of
places don't even have traffic laws like
we do and I've heard that those people
come to America and they're like we wish
we had laws like you guys do because I
was in Bolivia and dude would like it
was a two-lane road I guess but there
was three rows of cars for some reason
and they're like just inches from the
person in front of them and they just it
looked like there was no laws oh yeah
and there's no cops or anything yeah in
India it's like just just like the
traffic is just like flowing and then
what you know the ones that are going
this way the other ones from the other
side they just creep up and creep up
yeah until they just like squeeze the
other one
and that's how it works no stop lights
no stop signs nothing and what a great
example of why laws are good because you
don't want to get smashed by that yeah
you there's a red light I'm going to
wait because there's traffic going this
way it's protecting me yeah and God's
law is really protecting us from hurting
other people or hurting our relationship
with God you know it's it's it's it's a
simple concept that is really
interesting to let people fight against
that so much and I think that if you
really truly have a passion for God you
know just pray Lord help me to Delight
in your law just like David did he daily
had to come and when he messed up he was
like Lord don't turn your ear for me you
know like help me to keep falling in
love with you daily and doing what
you're asking me to do I think actions
speak louder than words you can look at
that in a relationship you know if you
you can tell your wife you love her
every day but if you don't show it in
any kind of way you don't spend time
whether you don't give her flower or any
of those things she's gonna be like well
I can't tell you love me you say it but
I don't I don't see it and we should do
that with God you know show me you love
me no no it's awesome
any closing thoughts anyone
God wants us to be extreme
for him right well I hope you guys are
blessed by today today's conversation uh
Justin is literally the most interesting
person we have sat in here all day long
and heard story after Story
um I wish we could share them all but uh
not all of them perhaps you'll have to
come on again and show us some more of
your crazy extreme family moments I've
always told this guy he needs a reality
show that's like literally all about you
know your life with all this chaos
of chaos right yeah sometimes we hope
you guys were blessed um but thank you
for stopping by
um thank you patreon donors for even
making this possible for us to continue
to do this type of work and we hope that
you guys were just inspired listen God
wants you to give him all of your heart
not part of your heart not some of your
heart he wants you to commit fully and
completely to him and I know if you do
that you will be blessed I guarantee it
or your money back yes well I should
probably be careful about that but you
will not be sorry that you gave God all
of you and we know that an awesome
reward is coming for those that love him
so we hope that's you guys leave a
comment in the section below if you want
to see some more videos with with Justin
check out the video we'll Link in the
screen here at the end of this video and
you can watch his other uh LED live that
he did with us but thanks for stopping
by and we'll see you guys next week
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
foreign
to do something that lets someone know
you're thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
foreign
Bible study Series where we will explore
a variety of Bible topics using video
and print what is humility do we need
God's law can I understand the Holy
Spirit yes you can and we're going to
solve that today in five minutes or less
they're designed to engage You by
watching a five-minute video having a
discussion on the topic and Diving
deeper into it with a lesson study
each study asks questions has discussion
points and or has activities
overall we developed this project for
you to have a closer walk with Jesus as
you explore relevant topics either in a
group setting or on your own we hope you
find these a blessing if you want more
information go to
www.littlelightstudios.tv or find us on
your favorite social media platform